certainly one of the biggest netflix
shows of all time had its ups and downs
for the cast and for the stars of
stranger things they may have had more
downs than one expects we got an inside
look into some of the most painful and
terrifying scenes cast members were a
part of and we'll explain why they're
not their most favorite ones too
number one a whole lot of action for
nothing yeah that's not what this cast
is about apparently while filming a
lengthy shootout scene in season 4 finn
wolfhard had a very frustrating
experience
he won't give us much about the scene
but we do know the group is caught up in
some sort of shootout with a bunch of
men in body armor the director explained
to them beforehand that they would need
to shoot this complex bit in one go so
every moving part needed to hit their
marks but unfortunately the first go was
nearly flawless that is until one of the
soldiers missed their mark we do
everything and then the camera whips to
the door and the soldier is not there
even after this first take wolfhard was
pretty ducked out but they had to just
keep pushing through till everything
came out perfectly
number two talk about a strange reaction
nobody ever knew where caleb mclaughlin
would take lucas sinclair in stranger
things and of all the scenes he deemed
uncomfortable he found a moment in
season 4 to take things off the rails
for him as caleb explains he and mason
dye who portrays jason carver have a
little tense showdown rather than stick
to the script all caleb could muster was
as this was the final episode of season
four he couldn't get into it too much
all we really know was that sadie sync
was confused and everybody else was just
laughing
like laughing
and it's just it was a running joke we
would never expect lucas would do
anything less bizarre this embarrassing
moment stuck with mclaughlin till the
end of the shoot which doesn't make this
his most favorite scene to shoot so
every time we had to do that scene oh
man number three we've all come to like
steve a little bit more especially after
season one but whether he was redeemed
or not we were a little happy he got
some payback with being tied up oh that
was actually pretty brutal to be honest
being tied together that was really
tough however we're not happy that the
awesome joe kiri looked back at this
scene as one of his least favorites as
steve is taken by the russians in season
three he's dragged and tied up by the
soldiers looked pretty painful to us and
apparently to joe it was as painful as
it looks and lengthy too he revealed
just the scene of him being tied up and
dragged took a whopping three days to
shoot definitely not a fun time on set
and we can only imagine how much the
scene dragged on for him but also when
you're doing it you're like you feel
pretty in it i guess number four seeing
how david harper gets along with
co-stars on every project he does we
were quite surprised to discover the one
cast member he loathed working with oh
my god i hated that dog this pooch was
not david's best friend in season one it
would run off on him a lot forcing
production to do multiple takes of all
their scenes and to make matters worse
it seemed like its trainer was in it for
all the wrong reasons i just remember
the trainer come on
we gotta make our money we would never
blame the poor pup for this one but due
to increasing frustrations from the
actor it was not asked to come back for
season 2. we hope it got a lot of treats
and maybe an emmy for his good boy
performance
number 5 you make me dizzy miss milly we
were just sitting and watching this and
even that made us sick millie bobby
brown divulged into what would be her
worst time filming a scene the scene in
question comes from season 3 episode 6
as 11 enters the chaotic mind of billy
and experiences a lot of twists and
turns of course they had to literally
twist and turn millie on a harness to
sell the effect what happens next well
she regretted it first of all and her
stomach did not appreciate it all that
flipping made her sick after the shoot
was over and let's just say we're happy
there's no behind the scenes video of
that number six heights are a no-go for
us and for gaydon matarazzo it's a
definite terrifying time to go up
against this one comes from the infamous
quarry scene in season 1 episode 6 as
dustin and mike run away from their
bullies they get dangerously close to a
cliff gayton being sincere was not only
concerned for his own safety but for
that of his co-star finn wolfhard we can
wholeheartedly agree thank goodness
eleven was there to save the day kick
yeah and still my hair is looking like
this
number seven how come no one's lost
their voice in stranger things because
we're surprised noah schnapp didn't lose
his in this scene alone we can remember
watching the possession of will in
season two and barely being able to
watch the terrifying moment but all noah
can recall is having to scream a lot
they had to collect so many takes of
just him screaming that it really took a
number on his vocal cords but he's a
professional and he's willing to go that
extra mile
number eight we all saw this one coming
and joe kiri was not looking forward to
it they'd never done anything like this
it was like the fight day you know billy
and steve face off resulting in a not so
favorable outcome for steve
he looked seriously terrified of billy's
rage and that acting was more authentic
than we like to think very into this
character and he was very you know he
was giving it his all joe was actually
terrified of daker montgomery's acting
in this moment that the emotion really
stuck with kyrie after filming
number nine a tearful reunion between
two friends always makes for the perfect
audience sob scene this hard-hitting
moment came from season 2 episode 7 when
11 reunites with callie milly reported
she could not keep it together here and
she really doesn't like taking the
emotions home offset but it
unfortunately did and it was hard of her
to let go of the heavy emotions during
the scene nobody likes crying and we can
only imagine how hard it was for her to
bounce back after this one i feel like i
don't need to go to therapy anymore
number 10 it's always surprising to see
that an unfavorable character is the
total opposite of their actor and as we
all know joe kiri is one of them he
recalls a moment in season one when
steve smashes jonathan's camera it made
us all really dislike his character and
he was right there with us kiri really
harps on hating these kinds of scenes
especially when it comes to bullying the
character of one of his best friends
behind the scenes charlie heaton i kind
of had a hard time sort of being mean to
charlie because i love charlie so much
he doesn't have a mean bone in his body
but his character definitely thinks
otherwise
number 11 we can all recall that lovely
time when bowl cuts were the new trend
wow what an awful time stranger things
actually revived the ancient trend
forcing noah schnapp to rock one in
every scene it's one of the best
one the best things on television
and the worst he's definitely a little
too young to remember how cool it was to
have one so he was not enjoying the
little throwback he insisted every
season to restyle or cut it but
filmmakers were just not going to budge
noah was never able to understand the
style questioning why doesn't will maybe
he shaves his head like really did
everyone have that haircut in the 80s
number 12. uh oh could we be having a
little co-star drama on our hands nope
not really but watching your partner
kissing another person might be
uncomfortable and this was the case for
charlie heaton and natalya dyer as she
was kissing joe kiri in season one we
can imagine it was a little
uncomfortable for heaton to say the
least but it seems like there's no beat
between him and joe as their friendship
seems to have moved past it plus it
looks like steve really didn't get to
have that relationship after the first
season so all that's in the past now
that's a whole lot of crazy experiences
for one big crazy show we'd like to hope
they had more favorite scenes but it's
hard to look past some of these moments
how awkward do you think it really was
for charlie heaton or did he even force
himself to watch that scene
let us know your thoughts in the
comments